[Music]
zack
what a time it has been oh my gosh the
country
is uh coming apart at the seams
um the capital hill riots
uh were something out of some kind of
dystopian reality and yet it is now our
reality
uh it's incredibly painful as we're
recording this
congress is considering impeachment
which i believe is
necessary and uh you can't not impeach
someone who sends a mob to your door
that
results in multiple deaths uh and so
despite the fact that trump's gonna be
out of there one way or another in a
week like i think that they need to
impeach
i read your book as many of the people
listening as podcasted you predicted a
lot of this
at least in various versions right how
do you feel watching it
play out i'm actually really curious and
where your brain is seeing like
yep we're talking about this for a while
and now it's happening now we have to
live it now we're talking about it
it's horrifying and as bad as i thought
things were going to get
even i did not think they were going to
get this bad this quickly in this form
um you know my big
takeaway for people is that uh
we should open our minds to the
possibilities both positive and negative
at this point you know like i mean if
you reflect on it
it's nearly unthinkable even our
day-to-day
where when you uh walk around
and see people with masks huddle
together and then all the signs saying
uh you know like uh stay
home stay safe and whatnot it's like
these are things that you would
have imagined in 2019 you'd be watching
a science fiction movie
um and then we went into that reality
very quickly
hundreds of thousands of people have
lost their lives
from the pandemic and i do think there's
been this massive
mental health toll on all of us
and if you take a population that was
strained to begin with
i believe there are a lot of people that
are breaking right now
and you know when people break uh
they're breaking in different ways
i agree i agree with you it's
heartbreaking and terrifying right where
it's
um terrifying that this is a threat to
the fabric of our democracy and that a
lot of
frankly the left has been clamoring that
this is what trump has been standing for
for a long time and the right was saying
yeah but there's
other values we care about more the left
doesn't stand for and it's worth it and
frankly the left proven right a little
bit on this um or very much so
well here here's the major thing i i
think and you can see it playing out
in that um there is one side that is
much more likely to show up to
a protest in quotes uh armed
uh and and there's one side that frankly
is going is
much more likely to get a pass from law
enforcement as we saw in capitol hill
and that is unfortunately the same side
and so you know when people try and do
the both sides ism
like they're very very uh different
dangers i mean if you look at the actual
toll of domestic terrorism
like you know right-wing terrorism is a
much more uh
real threat you know i was reading a
piece today about the
intersection between military background
and training
and extremism uh and they they talked
about two groups of people
one who were extremists who go into the
military to get trained and that's a
thing apparently
but there's also a thing where people
show up to the military and then become
extremists while they're in the military
frankly i've been just confused on a lot
of understanding
frankly the actions of the far right in
this case and then
navigating the the comparison with the
actions of the far left and so the
question that i've been getting or
comments i've been getting from the
from my republican friends have been
comparing it it's not the same but they
were bringing up the comparison to
portland where
the far left essentially just took over
the police station in a city essentially
for a month
um as an example of what happens in the
far left does things and now you have
the far right like storming the capital
help me understand what the like or help
our listeners understand the difference
between
those actions or how do we navigate well
my
my perception and i believe this is
borne out by facts
is that if you look at for example black
lives matter protests
uh the vast majority of them were
peaceful and unarmed
correct and and i'm going to suggest
that if they
were anything else there would have been
even higher degrees of violence
uh that um because law enforcement would
have been
uh cracking down immediately if like
folks were showing up
like i i think that there would have
been unthinkable even more unthinkable
um conflicts and scenes uh and again so
like that there
are um they're just very very different
levels of threat in my view from one
side versus the other
uh and you know i think that that's one
of the things like that
a lot of people find frustrating it's
like when people see this
unthinkable carnage on on capitol hill
and they say oh well portland it's like
a lot of people right now listen to this
being like are you kidding me
but but i've seen some of that stuff
online too where
um there's like a constant well what
about this well what about that yes that
is my point and i'm getting a lot of
what abouts
right yeah yeah that's like this
instinctive thing
and um you know one thing i said is that
look if any other group had done
this in the capital conservatives would
be calling for martial law right now you
know what i mean like
like they would look at this and say
this is like an act correct sedition
treason war like whatever it is but then
because it's
this particular group of people then
there is uh this what about like what
about you know what i mean like like
that there's like this
um and um the
to me extremism is like a massive
problem the extremism is a much more
virulent threat on the right because
it's much more likely to
um result in violence in in my view and
i think that's borne out by the facts
yeah um it is
heartbreaking to me that
and this i was kind of trying to grapple
with in the last election it's like
where do we draw the line between
country and party
and here we are the capital has been
stormed and blown through and we've got
literally people dragging a woman got
shot in the face like we have
uh uh like people posing with
like ripping apart the podiums or
whatever they're doing and we are still
in some minst is sticking to our party
lines and
that is frustrating you know what i'm
saying polarization
is destroying us uh and this is not a
both scientism thing it's like
you know i think most people know that
uh you know like i've i've campaigned
hard for democrats around the country
um and and you know like to me like
i'm much much more excited for president
joe biden than i would be a continuation
of trump error like you know
so this is not like a both sides
equivalent sort of thing but the
polarization is going to destroy us
because
um let's say you have republicans who
are horrified by what's going on and
they look up and say well what am i
going to do like
vote against my party uh you know it's
like like that the
polarization has gotten so extreme that
many people feel like it would be
very very damaging to their political
prospects if they
vote against their party's base in a
meaningful way it's one reason why trump
was able to run roughshod
on folks and there was one data point
that
made me really happy
or i wanted to elevate it so one of the
very very few republican senator
senators who came out and said
i've had enough like trump's need needs
to go was the alaska senator lisa
murkowski
and uh and trump i think at some point
signaled he's like ooh i'm gonna like
try and
have someone run against her like i'm
gonna have someone primary her
but alaska in november approved
ranked choice voting and open primaries
so there is no republican primary for
lisa murkowski as far as i know
it's just she shows up and it's like a
general
race and it's final four and ranked
choice
so that goes to show how changing the
mechanics
and getting rid of closed party
primaries actually can free
uh political figures because if you have
a closed party primary you're one
real viable threat is you get primaried
within your party and uh it's generally
from the most extreme wing
um and so if if you have an open primary
then you can be freed of that you can be
like look i'm gonna do what's reasonable
and a majority of people in my district
will actually like that as opposed to
the
most extreme 10 to 20 percent it is
amazing that we if we
fix the plumbing and the inner workings
a bit how much change that can have a
little bit of domino effect so
it's one reason we fight for it man we
can hone in on these individuals and the
individuals
are problems uh but there's something
that ezra klein said he said that
uh if a good individual hits a corrupt
system they'll get compromised
very quickly um and so you we have good
people hitting a
system that's corrupting them and
instead of expecting them to somehow
cleanse the system we have to try and
change it
so that they can be free to do something
that might not be
uh something that people in their party
are very excited about and still live to
you know serve
in in office because a lot of
politicians are like well if i do that
i'm going to lose so can't do that and
you know and that's one reason why we
feel so stuck
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by athletic greens
so i've learned to love this stuff i've
never been a big
diet supplement guy this one's pretty
easy either comes in you can do it in
like a bowl there's a big bowl you can
buy or you can get like these little
daily pouches but you throw it in some
water
it's tasty it's great and for me on
personal level it just helps it just
helps me digest things better
like no stomach pains whatever i eat
what i want
helps work out and i also know i'm
getting all those vitamins i'm supposed
to be getting
um in a healthy uh nutritious way
so it's essentially the most
comprehensive
daily nutritional beverage i've tried
probably out there in general so it's
got you get one scoop of this stuff it's
got 75 vitamins
and minerals and the whole food source
ingredients um
there's a multivitamin in there there's
multi-mineral probiotic green superfood
blend and more and they all work
together to fill the nutritional gaps in
your diet so
sometimes i don't eat enough vegetables
sometimes i don't eat enough
get enough vitamins or various proteins
things like that and it nails it for you
so i like it i take every morning it's
great and it tastes pretty freaking good
so
here's the deal athletic greens has this
awesome dietary supplement that works
with any diet so your
keto paleo vegan whatever the heck you
are it fits with all of it
and what they're doing is they're
doubling down on their awesome product
and giving you in addition
to your first purchase on athletic
greens giving you a one year supply of
vitamin d
which i have is pretty great and then
five free travel packs so you can try
out the travel pack as well with your
first purchase if you visit the link
today
all you gotta do is visit
athleticgreens.comyang
join the health experts athletes health
conscious go-getters and myself and
andrew
um as people around the world who are
using this making that daily commitment
to actually feeling better and eating
better and having that healthy diet
every single day
athleticgreens.com yang get your free
supply of vitamin d and five free travel
packs with them
right now
yank speaks is sponsored by skillshare
you guys gotta check this out because
the way
to learn cool new stuff particularly in
the creative realm i think i've said it
before i'm taking this class
through skillshare it's called plants at
home uplift your spirit and space
because i always i'm kind of envious
when people have like
green or shrubbery and greenery in their
homes and i always kill them so i've
learned not to over water my plants like
a dumbass and i've learned a bunch of
other things about how to
kind of make i got a new apartment like
how to make a home uh
a little bit better with some greenery
and how not to kill it and how to
balance it out so it's pretty cool but
there's a whole bunch of other classes
they got classes on iphone photography
they've got stuff
on how to be creative on creative online
they've got stuff called
find your style five exercises to unlock
your creative identity like there's
stuff on illustration graphic design
photography film video
productivity ui ux design creative
writing
whole bunch of different ways to learn
from other people with these skills to
unlock your own and it's pretty
freaking cool so it's this online
learning community
and it's a real fun way to grow this
year in 2021. it's also not that
expensive
it's incredibly affordable especially
compared to some of these pricing in
person classes so it's like
literally less than ten dollars a month
um and for us you're gonna get a free
trap
so if this is peaking your interest it
peaked mine i'm learning about plants
but if you don't learn about plants
learn about a whole bunch of other stuff
i just mentioned uh check it out
skillshare.com get a free trial of a
premium membership that's skillshare.com
what happens next wednesday when joe
gets inaugurated and how does this
do we start to transition or we still
get some unrest as
this happens i think that there are
going to be
um protests of some kind maybe not just
in dc i think there were 10 state
capitals that had some version of
protests i think that there will be
others um i don't think this is going
anywhere unfortunately
i think the fact that uh dozens of the
folks who
were in the capital are getting arrested
now
is a very big deal because typically
these kinds of movements have certain
people that are much much more energized
than others and so if you
uh imprison like that
uh group of people it's actually very
very significant
um but i do think there are going to be
protests i think one should be concerned
um but i i will also say that um from
everything i've seen
what happened in the capitol will not
happen again because
uh law enforcement the national guard
capital uh police and all others are
going to go from
frankly just completely botching this
and like you know like allowing
something
uh terrible to happen that could have
been much much worse to now
it's going to be like front center
buttoned up
fully staffed geared up um
like to the nth degree so at least on
that level
in a way i'd be more concerned about um
other
environments like state capitals because
i have a feeling that dc is going to be
a fortress
right for those of you who are
frustrated in protesting please be
peaceful and safe and those of you in
those neighborhoods or not please be
peaceful and safe
um and i think that the answer is or the
long and short of it is that the joe
biden administration called harris
administration they have their work cut
out for them um
and i hope we'll do everything we can to
help um
but we have to heal we got to heal as a
nation because this is not sustainable
this economy's not sustainable but this
polarization
this stuff you say this all the time
this gets worse before it gets better
i want to shift gears um we've got some
news that you announced today um
or late last night for recording this um
and want to basically talk about our
path forward on this podcast
yeah this is sort of a reflection
episode um where
you and i have been podcasting it up
since
march or so and i i have to say first i
want to say thank you thank you thank
you to everyone who's listening
uh really really appreciate your ongoing
support
and confidence and interest and belief
uh it means a ton to me zach and
everyone else who's associated with
uh our team uh it's been a blast
i have enjoyed this podcast um
every time where like i look forward to
it um and
we are going to be shifting gears uh
where
we've been doing monday and thursday and
you and i can talk about this a little
bit where yeah
we originally we're just going to do
once a week because that seemed to make
sense
but then because we were enjoying it so
much and having so many conversations
where we're like
let's go monday thursday monday thursday
and even then we weren't sure it was
going to be monday thursday
uh in perpetuity but we were having so
much fun and doing so much that it was
monday and thursday
for this first uh 10 months or so
but now we are going to switch gears and
make it once a week
mondays you know monday to look forward
to um we're going to have
maybe an occasional thursday but you can
fully expect and look forward to uh
yang speaks episode every monday ongoing
which is a bit of a shift in um but i
think you guys given the news that was
announced today
um understand that there's a lot on the
plate and we we are committed to doing
this well you know um and giving you
guys um kind of a national perspective
so this podcast will be separate from a
lot of the political activity you're
seeing from us on a day-to-day basis
and we think that's still a good thing
like this is a great venue for those who
don't live in
certain large cities or maybe around the
country but
um you have our word that it's still
going to be
yang speaks it's still going to be fun
you'll get both of us we're going to
make a commitment to this once a week
every monday
um and for any sort of political
activities you know where to find that
as well be separate from here
that said this can be a fun year like we
got we got big plans andrew
i'm excited the team's excited revved up
i mean when when push comes to shove and
this is something i hope that people
know and appreciate about me
um at the end of the day i'm a doer you
know what i mean like
like i love sitting down and talking to
folks and learning
uh and listening and
thinking and uh gathering my thoughts
and trying to
put ideas out that are going to help
people make sense of
the world but at the end of the day i
want to get [ __ ] done i mean that's just
the the real thing
we've gotten a lot of [ __ ] done this
past number
of weeks and months and reflecting on
i'm going to use this as an opportunity
to reflect a little bit
we helped get over 160 billion dollars
out to
american families and i i'm pretty sure
if this two thousand dollar bill
um uh two thousand dollar stimulus
checks passes we'll have something to do
with that too
uh because one of the things we did and
thank you to everyone who who helped
make this possible we helped flip the
senate
you know we spent weeks and weeks in
georgia
knocking on doors and volunteering and
doing things uh and
i have a very very strong feeling that
if we get two thousand dollar
checks uh that john ossoff and reverend
warnock will be right there voting for
it
we've given almost 10 million dollars
away to folks um
you know over the last year uh to people
who are struggling
um there's so many accomplishments in
the last 10 months it's been an
incredible journey
uh you know i i'll i'll say one reason
i'm so grateful everyone listening to
this it's like i feel like the energy
around
this movement has grown significantly
since the presidential and that was
really
my big goal was that at the end of the
presidential i was like we have to keep
this ship
sailing and moving and bringing on new
passengers
and it has happened and now we're going
to try and get some more stuff done
um and have a have a good time and have
some great conversations
one thing about this podcast is that
like i i do
love to interact with people and learn
from them and just
uh you know pick their brains and we're
just going to keep on doing it
20 21. no matter what we're doing on
this podcast or how who's probably on
this podcast
we will always be doing we'll have we'll
be doing something in real life
whether it's a company you're starting
or humane
or running for office or whatever it is
right um and that's just how this goes
guys we're going to be
like updating you in real time on
various things and um
or talking about something else while
you know we're doing other various
things so and that's i think what makes
it fun and i hope you guys have enjoyed
it we've loved you
um and yeah andrew here's the 2021 man
let's uh let's have some fun 2021
may it be vastly superior to the year
that preceded it
though i have to admit zack it is off to
a very rocky start
uh but we're we're gonna yeah hopefully
we can turn that around
hopefully we can turn that around gang
all right all right guys
thank you for tuning in we will see you
monday and every monday going forward
stay awesome yang gang talk to you soon
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]